I just saw something unsettling on Fox
News and no it wasn't yet another piece
about the alleged war on Christmas which
actually sounds like the premise of an
awesome action what I saw was a colony
of bats bats his fox's acronym for big
area touch screens fox is doing what the
makers of ender's game and Minority
Report did come up with a non intuitive
and awkward interface in an attempt to
make human-computer interaction look
cool back in the olden days when
primitive humans communicated mostly
with speech it was easy to dramatize
conversations guys and dolls could
actually look dynamic using telephone
seamless pres Rome huh wait a minute oh
hello Sarge McHugh talking old align
whatever fine you can even build
suspense and drama around a chat just
let me you seen it with the language and
everything look around you there's
nothing dramatic or exciting about
people using keyboards for example watch
this
there I just delivered a blistering
Facebook beat down to some pathetic
hater who doesn't appreciate Warren
Ellis is run on L blazer my target is
probably curled up in the fetal position
now but all you saw was me staring
slack-jawed and a screen like a
and that presents a terrible dilemma for
the entertainment biz how do you ring
drama out of that well like this
apparently the media is trying to
convince us that in the future user
interfaces will have us all performing
balletic gesture said windmill swipes if
modern media barons were smart they pour
money into cutting-edge research a voice
recognition and natural language
processing open the pod bay doors hell
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that there now that's dramatic Kubrick
was right about everything what's the
most ludicrous interface you've seen in
a movie let me know in the comments